news comes out
trump's being banned permanently by
twitter
jack dorsey announces that then it's
facebook they don't say permanently
but they're kind of taking them down for
now youtube says for now but we'll see
what's going to happen in the future the
only one that used
the award permanently is dorsey
on twitter okay and you know
you've been in the space of creating
content for a while some of the stuff
you've said it's upset a few people you
had one legendary interview that uh
uh uh did very well where the lady was
trying to spook you and then next thing
you know it backfired on her and
you asked her a question and he said
gotcha and that kind of led to you know
all these different things and
even some of the things that was going
on in toronto when you were a teacher
there were some challenges there were
trans
gender whatever was going on and you
came out and spoke up and there was some
kind of a
debate that came up from that but uh
trump being banned alex jones a few
years ago
twitter youtube infowars they're coming
after they're doing this
okay what was your reaction when you
heard about the fact that the 45th
president united states was being
banned permanently in a very powerful
virtual
government called twitter well
i thought that the companies who are
doing such things have no idea what
responsibility they're
taking on because now they've announced
their
willingness or maybe even their
responsibility depending on how you look
at it
to police the content of what's being
exchanged on their
networks well that's a
rabbit hole that you in all likelihood
don't want to go down
so
you see attempts to censor emerging
quite constantly now
and it's it's it's very dangerous
it's very dangerous it's very upsetting
that this happened
to the president to elected president
what's what's the
you're someone who's well read you've
read history what has been the
consequences
of silencing someone
that has a big following who ends up
paying a price long term
is it the individual that silence say
trump is it his following or is it the
silence sir
who eventually created more enemies that
backfired on them
long term who ends up losing long term
well everybody does i would say because
the classic defense for free speech is
that you know if you
limit someone's free speech not only do
you limit the rights of the person who's
speaking but you limit the rights of
those who could have heard
and it seems to me that
people i believe that people have the
intelligence to make up their own minds
and that they should have
the information presented presented to
them my experience has been that
people have people are far more
intelligent
and perspicacious then then we generally
assume
they they come to the right conclusions
the right conclusions who's to say but
you know i i don't think there's
anything more important than freedom of
speech
so maybe maybe maybe let me ask the
question a different way let me ask a
question a different way so
we have a lot of different issues that's
being talked about right now things are
interchanged and obviously we've kind of
known what direction we're going
we have joe biden as our president i'd
rather hear what trump is thinking
than not i'd rather know than not
i'd rather see what's happening out in
the public than not
i i don't know what's going on
underground now
i don't i have no idea and i know that
and no one knows what the impact of this
has been on
all the people who supported trump what
are they supposed to conclude precisely
from this i'd rather these things were
out in the open
i don't think that these companies had
the right to do what they did
they had the right legally they had the
right
um obviously because they did it and
they got away with it um but
you know there's a technological problem
at the bottom of it too we have all
these new communication technologies and
we don't really know what the rules are
none of us do including the people who
run the these
social networks it's not like they
understand what they've created
how could you no one can understand them
what you've created
you know i was just talking to michael
malus the other day about 4chan
4chan had some effect on the hillary
trump election
it's possible that 4chan tilted the
election in favor of trump because the
margin was pretty small
but in any case 4chan in some sense
doesn't even exist
there's no centralized authority there's
no
administrative bureaucracy every you can
post there anonymously and
your posts disappear but we don't know
anything about
how to regulate on an at a
communications apparatus like this
or even how it should be regulated in
principle or even what it does
or what it is and so i have some
sympathy for the
giant media corporations because they're
dealing with intractable problems but
i still believe that the censorship road
is
well it's likely to lead to a place that
people don't want to go
so which is what
well part of its second guessing you
know
you you want to be able to say what you
think and if you have the voice of a
hypothetical sensor in your head i mean
i've experienced this already i've had
guests on my show like abigail schreier
who wrote a book on
um on on the trans
uh issue trend surgery in particular uh
gender reassignment surgery and i was
very
nervous about having the discussion
so there was the little sensor inside my
head already
operating and when enough sensors
operate in your head then you can no
longer think and if you can no longer
think
well then you can't see and you're blind
and you stumble into holes and
and everyone stumbles into holes and
that's not good
and you know it i've said over and over
that if you're discussing something that
matters
the probability that you're going to
offend someone is rises to virtual
certainty
if if the discussion you're having about
an important issue
is not
isn't of sufficient potency to offend
someone then you're not saying anything
at all well then how many people should
you offend
or can you offend before you're properly
banned
you know you can say well a line was
crossed because the president of the
united states
fomented armed insurrection well
had the situation be not clear he would
have been impeached
so there's ambiguity around the
circumstances well a line was obviously
crossed well what line
exactly and who's going to decide when
it's crossed
exactly and this is very troublesome but
it's a problem we all have like it's not
a problem
in some sense it's not a problem that
jack dorsey has or
or um or mark zuckerberg
they're they're facing the same set of
issues that the rest
of it are facing i mean they have more
authority over their platform obviously
but
it's not like there's a bunch of us out
here who have the answer and
they could just come asking we're all
facing this
mystery which is what our technological
transformation of our means of
communication what it means
and what we should do with it
it's very complicated what should we do
with what should i mean you're trying to
answer that question all the time what
should you do with your podcast what
should you do with your youtube channel
it's complicated you have an unlimited
bandwidth
and you have the opportunity to do every
anything you want and share it with
hundreds of thousands of people
okay what should you do you know you
have enough money
and so you know because one simple
answer to a problem is well i'll do what
makes money it's like okay well now you
have the money okay now what you should
what should you do
well it's complicated it's really
complicated and
and so we need to talk about what we
should do
and we are in fact doing that so that's
right it seems to be working
so so so let me ask you this today you
know i feel like every decade every era
there's different set of problems i
don't even think it's an era i think
it's decade like
you know sorry i'd like to sit down with
trump and and talk to him
like i'm talking to you because i'd like
to know what he's thinking
and i think everybody should know what
he's thinking and it isn't obvious to me
that i could do a youtube interview with
donald trump and have it aired
and that seems to be a problem because
don't we want to know what he's thinking
don't we want everyone else to see what
he's thinking
you know whether you're a foe or a
friend well we should know
and i've been inviting politicians onto
my show it's like come on for two hours
and
let's have a talk it's not sound bites
it's
it's an opportunity for you to reveal
yourself
can you will you what happens when you
do so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you